Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Recouvrant plus de 70% de notre planète,
nos océans régulent notre climat
et permettent également de transporter des
biens et des services à travers le monde.
En 2050, on estime que le trafic maritime
va augmenter entre 250 et 1 000%.
Et dans ce contexte
de changement climatique
et également d’augmentation
de nos activités maritimes,
on développe des nouvelles technologies
afin de limiter nos impacts
et également d’augmenter
la surveillance de nos océans.
Donc j’aimerais maintenant vous
présenter un système de surveillance
qui a nécessité énormément d’efforts
et d’années pour être mis en place.
Ce système consiste en une constellation
d’unités entièrement autonomes
qui fonctionnent
avec un carburant biodégradable
qui lui permet de fonctionner pendant
des années sans aucune maintenance.
Chaque unité est capable de transmettre
de l’information à une autre.
Elles sont toutes dotées
de capteurs sensoriels
et d’un système de navigation précis
qui leur permettent non seulement
de surveiller nos océans,
mais également d’échantillonner nos océans
sur des milliers de kilomètres.
La manière dont elles sont construites
leur permet également
d’emmagasiner des tonnes de carbone
pendant leur fonctionnement.
Et les rejets de leurs moteurs
permettent de remettre
en circulation des éléments
qui sont limitants
pour la production du phytoplancton.
Le phytoplancton, ce sont des micro-algues
qui ont une capacité
de séquestration du carbone
quatre fois supérieure
à la forêt amazonienne.
Donc le succès du système,
il est indéniable.
On a déjà dans nos océans plus de 15 000
exemplaires déployés à travers le monde.
Ça, c'est pour notre plus gros modèle.
Mais j’aimerais vous présenter
sans plus attendre...
la baleine bleue.
Quarante millions d’années
de recherche et de développement.
Une durée de vie de 90 ans.
Une longueur de 30 mètres.
Un poids moyen de 160 tonnes.
Elle a une capacité d’emmagasiner
33 tonnes de carbone au cours de sa vie.
Et les déchets qu’elle rejette permettent
la croissance du phytoplancton,
qui est un des plus grands puits
de carbone de notre planète.
On a 12 autres espèces de
grandes baleines dans le monde
qui sont distribuées
à travers tous nos océans,
tels que le rorqual à bosse
ou le rorqual commun.
Il faut savoir qu’on compte à peu près
un million de ces baleines.
Ce n’est même pas 50 %
de la capacité qu’on pourrait avoir.
C'est un marché énorme.
On pourrait augmenter les rendements.
Si on mettait un peu d’effort
et d’attention,
on serait capable de le faire.
J’aimerais maintenant que
vous imaginiez une seconde
si j’avais réellement inventé
un système comme ça -
un système qui ne pollue pas, autonome,
qui nous permet d’avoir une idée
de la santé de nos océans
et qui en plus nous aide dans la lutte
contre le changement climatique -
je serais milliardaire.
J’aurais plein d’actionnaires et
d’investisseurs qui seraient derrière moi.
Et pour ceux qui ne seraient pas
encore sûrs, je leur dirais : « Écoutez,
en plus, le design de mes baleines,
c’est si populaire
que ça génère une industrie touristique
de 2 milliardsde dollars par an.
Ce n’est pas mal.
Un des défis qu’on a maintenant,
c’est d’augmenter notre capacité
de surveillance de ces baleines
à grande échelle.
L’environnement de nos océans
est en train de changer rapidement.
On le voit.
On aperçoit des changements
de distribution majeurs de nos espèces
et notamment les changements
de distribution dans les eaux canadiennes
avec l'apparition de la baleine franche
qui arrive de plus en plus dans nos eaux.
Avec l’augmentation du trafic maritime
qui amplifie les risques de collision,
ça peut créer beaucoup de dégâts.
Si vous étiez un investisseur
et un actionnaire,
vous voudriez non seulement
qu’on surveille vos biens,
qu’on les protège
et qu’on fasse en sorte qu’on augmente les
effectifs pour augmenter vos rendements.
J’aimerais donc vraiment
qu’on arrête de penser
que d’investir dans la protection
des baleines est une dépense,
mais que c’est en réalité un
investissement qui peut rapporter gros.
Un des moyens qu’on a
pour surveiller les baleines,
ce sont les survols aériens.
En tant que biologiste,
je participe à ces survols aériens.
Sur le papier, c’est très très simple.
La première fois que j’ai fait un survol,
j’avais lu mon protocole
qui m’explique qu’il fallait
que j’identifie la baleine -
Une fois que j’observe quelque chose
et que j’identifie le type de baleine,
le nombre, la composition du groupe -
à savoir s’il y a des adultes,
des jeunes, des nouveau-nés -
et également, idéalement, leur activité
et la direction par rapport à l’avion.
Jusque-là, pourquoi pas ? Super.
Me voilà à ma première journée.
Je m’installe.
À quoi ça ressemble ?
Vous vous installez dans l’avion,
c’est assez étroit.
On vous met un casque.
Et vous regardez par un petit hublot,
une bulle de plexiglas qui vous permet
de rentrer votre tête et d’aller observer.
Pour que vous puissiez
prendre vos données,
on va vous donner un petit enregistreur
et un laser qui va permettre de
pointer la baleine pour la localiser.
Super. J’étais content,
c’était ma première journée.
Il était tôt, j’avais pris mon café.
On part en vol.
Super.
Au bout de quelques minutes,
avec un peu d’anxiété,
je m’aperçois que j’ai envie d’aller
aux toilettes, je demande où elles sont.
Il n'y en a pas.
Alors je prends la position
que tout le monde connaît :
je croise les jambes.
Je commence à activer un peu
les jambes afin de garder
tout ce que je dois garder en moi pendant
les quatre prochaines heures.
Par la suite, on arrive
sur la zone d’observation.
On me dit : « Allez-y, ça commence. »
Et là, vous essayez de passer
votre tête avec votre casque,
votre enregistreur et votre laser.
Tout ça dans le hublot.
Et c’est parti !
Vous vous retrouvez à peu près comme ça.
Au bout de cinq minutes,
vous commencez à réaliser qu’il y a une
douleur dans le bas du dos qui revient :
c’est votre nerf sciatique
qui s’est encore bloqué
et vous regrettez d’avoir arrêté
le yoga à ce moment-là.
Vous continuez, vous observez la mer
et rien ne se passe, rien ne se passe.
Et là, première observation !
Vous étiez impatient de cette première
observation, et ça fait comme ça :
Pfff !
Et c'est tout.
Et là, un petit moment de solitude.
Vous réalisez que finalement, quand vous
volez à 200 km/h, à 300 mètres d’altitude,
ce n’est pas si facile que ça
d’identifier les baleines.
Vous vous apercevez que, finalement,
si vous arrivez à identifier
vos baleines correctement
et à avoir un nombre
qui se rapproche de la réalité,
vous êtes satisfait.
Donc vous oubliez
la composition des groupes -
ou sinon de manière anecdotique.
Voilà comment on fait nos survols aériens.
Heureusement,
on peut améliorer cette méthode.
L’une des manières, c’est d’installer
des caméras dans l’avion,
ce qui va permettre de prendre
des photos tout au long du vol
à intervalles réguliers.
L’avantage de la capture d’image,
c’est que vous allez pouvoir
mieux identifier vos baleines.
Vous allez pouvoir récupérer d’autres
informations sur les populations
telles que la composition des groupes -
à savoir s’il y a des adultes
ou des juvéniles -
ce qui va vous indiquer également
en quelle santé sont nos populations.
Est-ce qu’elles sont en bonne santé ?
Pensez-vous que les effectifs vont
augmenter dans le futur ou pas ?
Le problème avec cette méthode, c’est
que ça génère énormément de données.
Donc vous allez avoir
des centaines de milliers d’images.
Quand ça arrive, ce que l’on fait -
C’est le biologiste qui est dans l’avion
qui essaie de prendre
ses données d’observation.
Une fois qu’il a trop d’informations,
parce qu’il y a tellement de groupes
de baleines qui passent,
on switche en mode photographique.
Donc on va prendre les photos,
et une fois arrivé à terre,
on va analyser ces photos.
ça peut être 15, 20 000 photos
analysées par la suite.
Tout est fait à la main encore.
C’est un biologiste comme moi
qui regarde les photos
et qui va identifier
et localiser les baleines.
Ça peut prendre plusieurs mois.
Des fois, vous allez faire votre survol
en juillet d’une année
et vous allez avoir vos résultats
uniquement l’année [suivante].
Ce n'est pas idéal.
Maintenant, en étant au 21ᵉ siècle,
on est capable d’utiliser une technologie
qui a révolutionné nos vies
jusqu’à présent :
c'est l'intelligence artificielle.
J’aimerais maintenant
vous montrer une photo.
Cette photo a été prise dans l’Arctique
canadien par Pêches et Océans Canada
lors des survols de narvals.
Les narvals, ce sont
les cousins des bélougas
et généralement on les identifie par la
présence d’une défense sur les mâles.
On a créé un algorithme qui
permet, comme vous le voyez,
de délimiter toutes les baleines
sur la photo.
Lorsque vous créez une solution comme ça
d’intelligence artificielle,
votre algorithme ne va jamais
être parfait.
Il va faire des erreurs et c'est normal.
La première chose que l’on va intégrer,
c’est ce qu’on appelle un expert
dans la boucle, qui est moi.
En un sens, il va falloir le nourrir,
votre algorithme,
lui donner plein d’amour.
S’il fait des erreurs, ce n’est pas grave.
On va l’aider à reconnaître les cibles.
Ce que ça permet de faire,
c’est que vous avez augmenté
votre capacité d’analyse de photos.
Vous allez pouvoir atteindre votre
objectif de 50, 100, 200 000 photos
dans un temps beaucoup
plus court qu’il aurait été prévu.
Donc tout d’un coup, vous pouvez faire
des survols aériens
uniquement photographiques,
ce qui réduit les risques de mettre
des gens comme moi dans des avions
dans des régions éloignées.
En plus, vous allez pouvoir récupérer
plus d’informations sur vos populations.
L’autre avantage
de l’intelligence artificielle,
c’est que vous allez pouvoir aller
chercher d’autres plateformes
qui sont encore peu utilisées, telles
que les drones et les images satellites,
et vous allez pouvoir couvrir des zones
où on n’a jamais été capables d’aller.
Un dernier point, c’est que,
lorsque l’on fait les analyses d’images
avec des observateurs comme moi,
on se retrouve avec des variabilités dans
la manière dont on annote ces images.
Parce qu’une baleine à la surface,
c’est très simple de l’identifier.
Mais quand elle va être plus bas
dans la colonne d’eau,
ça va devenir plus difficile.
Et surtout quand il y a des groupes où
il y en a qui vont être tellement profonds
qu’un observateur va dire :
« Je vois quelque chose,
peut-être une baleine. »
pendant qu’il y en a un autre
qui va déterminer que ça en est une.
Quand vous utilisez
l’intelligence artificielle,
ça permet de standardiser vos méthodes.
J’aimerais vous rappeler que, cette année,
on a observé des températures
de 30 °C au-dessus des normales
saisonnières en Arctique
et 40 °C en Antarctique.
Les technologies qu’on développe de
lutte contre le changement climatique,
ça nous aide à diminuer nos impacts,
mais il ne faut pas penser
que ces technologies peuvent remplacer
ce que la nature nous offre,
notamment les baleines.
Il va falloir qu’on commence
à repenser notre économie
pour prendre en compte véritablement
la valeur des populations de baleines
et la valeur du vivant en général,
afin qu’on puisse les protéger
et les surveiller de manière adéquate.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)